welcome to behind the scenes of our
writing a very quick reading at VidCon
dramatic writing with grace it's ready
with grace because I really don't want
to write this whole thing by myself it's
writing with grace riding with me me my
name is Grace
I'm signing 2,000 copies abrasive style
TR pretending you have it ATT as
wonderfully purchase 50,000 copies of my
book banks agency to give back to you
guys that kind of supported as the
random phrase series at VidCon we're
going to be giving some out I'm gonna
beat in your face whether you want me
there or not we're packing up brace
March bag next is the hall race merch
for VidCon
grains are so cool because it's really
inspiring to see someone her level be so
true to herself you know submitted
chapters that are part of free quick
don't run after vidcon's
and they're here I'm gonna meet them I'm
so excited like I'm going to prom and
I'm meeting my date
sited I never had anything that I
written spoken into a huge crowd like
this so I'm super excited super nervous
and probably I was panicked when I found
out I was going to be flown here I
freaked out so much and scared my cat
huge shout out to graze time everyone
ever written the phrase to AT&T like
this is so much more than I could have
asked for really thank you
everyone should have it spread you're
gonna get hi I'm Jon Cozart I'm reading
the part of Jim is mighty mallards a
school mascot I'll be playing the future
role my name is Hannah and I'll be
playing banana I get it I like freak
week to end before you bunch of idiots
finally accepted your true feelings your
true selves hi my memory Hart and I'll
be playing the role of Marmee
thanks [ __ ] who wrote that lame-o and
I'm the narrator today I'm Harley and I
play the role of pirates I already
forgot Snow White
my name is Jessie and I am playing the
role of loudmouth aka and western hardly
similar to my name I'm not sure if
there's a connection there
I feel like there was anyone tries to
fix my character banana I was worried I
was least prepared but it turns out no
one's ready so it's just like high
school
none of us have done our heart oh my god
I have to rap
it's really amazing your head well
producing everything you've ever done
and also all the chapters every other
Oh chill who are these writers when they
help much of my script very relieving
I'm doing it it was so much fun oh my
gosh I've never been happier to be a
doctor nail that performance of a
lifetime
send calls to my agent I own a chest got
a good staff voice I'm sorry yeah if
people made fun of me back cinch but
apparently it paid off because if you
liked it enjoyed themselves on any small
without feeling slightly
well there you go that was our VidCon
experience with freak week and the live
table read and you guys thank you if you
were there in person it was a really
amazing time if you weren't able to come
to VidCon and you still want to see the
entire live reading of freak week make
sure that you go check out the AT&T
hello lab channel oh dad surprised are
you happy with your choices I don't know